on voit qu'il ya beaucoup de jeunesse
qui est venu enrichir le bonheur est
vraiment
à l'extérieur je voulais un peu plus de
quiétude carolanne pierre philippe et
marc ont choisi de quitter montréal pour
queens ville petite ville de 15 mille
habitants des cantons de l'est un peu
plus d'une heure de route de la
métropole
le stress pour bien des choses j'ai
beaucoup moins pas de problème de
circulation penser à trouver petit ou
qu'on était une question système de
santé oms notre médecins les hôpitaux
tout c'était plus près pour nous plus
facile l'accès si j'avais besoin je
pense de donner à mes enfants des
espaces verts
la proximité avec la nature tous les
trois travaillent maintenant ici
carolanne qui est coiffeuse a emménagé
au mois de juin
originaire de koans ville elle rentre
donc au bercail en allant ailleurs que
j'ai réalisé ce que j'avais j'ai un
point d'accès un lac ou par prêt j'ai
dit mon temps que je peux aller monter
en cinq minutes g descente et jusque là
bas ou qui est ce pas les marchés le
bonheur serait-il plus loin de montréal
un sondage commandé par radio canada
démontre en tout cas que plus on
s'éloigne et plus la fierté et la
satisfaction envers sa ville est grande
71% des répondants montréalais ont dit
avoir une bonne opinion de leur ville à
laval c'était 81% à longueuil 85% dans
la couronne nord 91 % d'opinions
favorables et dans la couronne sud 94%
le sondage nous apprend aussi que 42 %
des montréalais songe à quitter la ville
au cours des prochaines années surtout
parce que c'est trop cher
koans ville attire de plus en plus de
gens la maison moyenne tourne autour de
220 à 225 mille dollars
donc ça c'est très intéressant quelqu'un
qui arrive de l'extérieur peut acheter
une propriété ici puis encore avoir des
sous pour faire des l'oise et on se dit
qu'on est une municipalité à couleurs
humaine donc c'est sûr que quand on se
promène et toujours quelqu'un qui nous
dit bonjour ça nous prend plus de taf à
l'épicerie les résultats du sondage
n'ont pas tellement surpris ses deux
professeurs de l'école d'urbanisme de
l'université de montréal direct de la
corpiq à montréal
des vélos ont fuit encore davantage
action aux états unis les bénéfices
d'habiter en ville pendant la coved sont
beaucoup moins importants surtout ceux
du centre-ville
c'est quand que les les reproches qu'on
ferme montréal concerne toute une série
de dossiers sont caractéristiques des
descentes des problèmes qu'on n'a pas en
banlieue et problème montréalais on n'a
pas à bond à main on a par là tous les
jours dans les médias les problèmes de
la banlieue on en parle très peu des
problèmes souvent lié au manque de
services que ce soit en matière
d'infrastructures de commerce ou de
divertissement c'est plate que pop punk
cette rencontre entre les petites villes
du coin
au début on avait juste un auto sinon on
est rendu avec deux autres est-ce que
des choses qui vous manque de monde
oui oui mais en ce moment c'est
accessible donc les milieux culturels et
même soir que s'est fait tout seul c'est
sur la proximité c'est des fois ça
manque pour aller faire le marché et
tout s'apprend à votre même encore
aujourd'hui les taux d'inoccupation des
logements à montréal sont à un niveau
très très beau avoir un niveau record
donc il n'y a jamais eu autant mende qui
ont voulu vivre à montréal en même temps
que maintenant malgré la coved
mais carol ann marc et pierre philippe
ne reviendront pas à montréal leur
nouvelle vie les rend heureux
la métropole après tout n'est qu'à une
heure s'ils ont envie d'y aller